-Welcome back, guys.
The big movie this weekend
is "The Batman."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It is getting great reviews,
and IMAX screenings are selling
out all over America.
So I thought it would be fun
to go around the studio
and see who can give the best,
"I'm Batman."
I'll go first.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Deep voice ] I'm Batman.
And I'm vengeance.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Normal voice ] Felt good.
Higgins, why don't you give us
your best, "I'm Batman"?
-Okay.
[ Dramatic music plays ]
[ Deep voice ] I'm Batman, and
I'm here to save Gotham City.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
Why are you smiling at the end?
-I'm smiling.
-Yeah, you don't smile
at the end.
That's a very good Batman.
James, can we see your Batman?
[ Laughter ]
-[ Deep voice ] I'm Batman.
You don't want to mess with me
'cause I have
a lot of great ideas
and just don't tell them
to many people.
[ Laughter ]
They'll laugh at me
but not anymore.
[ Laughter ]
I made a website.
It's www.spaceport.spaceport
dot dot James Poyser's
Batman ideas dot piano.
[ Laughter ]
See you on the information
superhighway.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter continues ]